the out of control border crisis under
president biden exposing the threat from
cartels and smugglers the new york post
reporting quote in addition to the
cocaine methamphetamine and fentanyl
that they smuggle across the border both
the sinaloa and juarez cartels who
dominate parts of northern mexico have
branched out into smuggling desperate
migrants according to authorities on
both sides of the border with more on
this tom homan fox news contributor and
former acting ice director
tom
welcome thanks for having me so we know
these cartels are vicious what is the
impact on truly desperate migrants
well look the criminal cartels in mexico
they controlled the northern border
mexico so even before they got in the
business
of trafficking women children smuggling
uh migrants
the the smuggling organization had to
pay a pay a plasma fee a tax to work
through the area of control so they
always been involved but these cartels
were ruthless that's why i said a lot of
people attacked the trump administration
you know where i worked saying the
policies were you know inhumane let me
remind them illegal immigration was down
83 percent
a 35-year low so when it's that low when
when the organizations aren't moving
people
less women are being sexually assaulted
less children are being abandoned in the
desert to die
less children are drowning and look less
migrants die bottom line is a secure
border saves lives so call trump
policies whatever you want but we saved
thousands of lives i talked to one
sheriff in south texas just last week
one share has already found over 60 dead
migrants in his county people that died
in making this journey
we know these
cartels are transnational organizations
they have violent turf wars with each
other protecting their smuggling routes
what's the impact on our men and women
at the border
well look they're overwhelmed like the
border patrol was already on record 40
to 50 percent of their manpower is no
longer on the line because they're in
facilities processing people when half
the border patrol is not on the line
that's when these criminal cartels take
advantage of these of these of these
gaps during the del rio crisis 224 miles
of border were unguarded last week in
yuma every bourbon tradition was pulled
in to process these family groups and
hundreds were crossing the line walking
into the city of yuma unimpeded so that
borbacho's already overwhelmed and these
cartels are ruthless this is when they
start moving the fentanyl that's killed
over a hundred thousand people this year
it's not a coincidence coincidence at
the highest
level of illegal immigration this year
record numbers illegal immigration and
joe biden at the same time record number
of fentanyl overdoses it's because the
borders open the border is vulnerable
and there's big gaps and the cartels are
taking advantage of it
texas congressman henry cuellar a
democrat represents about 200 miles of
the border
he had a stunning quote about vice
president kamala harris to the new york
times let's put it on the screen he said
i say this very respectfully to her i
moved on she was tasked with that job it
doesn't look like she's very interested
in this so we're going to move on to
other folks that work on this issue
reminder he's a democrat
tom
what's his options to work with state
officials to try to get a handle on the
border
yeah i think he can work with the
governor of texas he also worked with
arizona government look
henry cuellar's a patriot look i don't
always agree with his stances but let me
tell you something he believes in a
secure border he wants to protect
migrants from the death and the mayhem
that they're getting put through right
now these cartels he wants texas to be
safe he wants the laws in force and he
also wants some sort of fix of this
whole immigration crisis and and if the
laws don't work then fix them he's a
common sense a congressman i don't care
he's a democrat republican he's always
been a common sense guy and i respect
him greatly but look the governor of
texas is stepping up he's he's a real
secretary of homeland security because
alejandro mayorgas hasn't done a thing
to secure the border or slow the flow
but governor abbott has
government the state of arizona is
stepping up the state of florida is
stepping up so states are stepping up
because because the federal government
has advocated their responsibility to
secure this border which you're required
to do under the
constitution part of the congressman's
frustration is likely the fact the vice
president has not been to his district
which again has about 200 miles of
international border
tom homan we have to leave it there
thank you so much for your time sir
thanks for having me hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else